kourtney kardashian just tattooed i love
you
on travis barker's arm i love you
while a source tells e.t the two are
talking about getting engaged
and married i love it on wednesday the
keeping up with the kardashians star
posted
these snaps to instagram giving her
boyfriend
some new ink
she captioned with her latest resume
credit writing quote i
tattoo and travis he slid into the
comments to give his lady love
props writing woman of many talents
and his 17 year old son landon also
praised her skills
writing looks so fire so what did the
woman of many talents ink on travis's
body
three magical words i love you
this is such a dream come true the blink
182 drummer posted a pic
of the finished product to his insta
story calling court the best tattoo
artist
of course the musician's new tat comes
after he had courtney's name inked on
his chest
the push founder has been dating travis
for a few months now
and a source tells e.t the two have been
talking about forever
quote travis would absolutely love to
tie the knot with courtney but courtney
hasn't been sure that's the step she
wants to take in their relationship
right now
she is extraordinarily happy and doesn't
feel the need or want the pressure of
getting married
the source adds that there are other
factors she's considering like her kids
and what that adjustment would mean for
them it could be a lot to process
even though everyone sees that courtney
is undeniably in love with travis
courtney sees herself loving this moment
and is just taking everything one day at
a time
and enjoying their time together i'm
just like living life
and whatever happens happens of course
courtney shares three children
eleven-year-old mason
eight-year-old penelope and six-year-old
reign with her
ex scott disick while travis has two
children
seventeen-year-old landon and
fifteen-year-old alabama from his
marriage to shayna mochler
he helped me learn about music a lot
and also just watching him on tours
always
made me more confident and happy and
etisour says travis's loving role as
dad is just one of the many things she
adores about him
travis makes courtney laugh
uncontrollably and she loves that he
always brings a smile to her face
as for travis he loves court's
entrepreneurial spirit and that she's a
strong
independent mom quote they feel like
they're the perfect match
the source also says that court's famous
family really loves travis
and holds him in high regard quote what
they appreciate the most
is how he takes such great care of
courtney and always has her best
interest in mind